we take the carbon atoms in this lump of
coal they're not worth very much because
they're random and unstructured but if
we were to take those same atoms and
rearrange them into a crystal their
diamond I started cybex in 97 I had a
successful software company before that
I sold that for a lot of money and that
has allowed me to invest more money in
nano than any human on the planet so I'm
either the greatest fool that you've
ever seen or I have a vision that maybe
I haven't yet achieved that says this is
worth spending my life's fortune on and
my life's time so we built a number of
products along the way I've been
involved since even before I started
cybex endow define minh prize in
nanotechnology that is a a prize which
will go to the embodiment of a
particular nano tech device along the
way we're giving yearly awards which
have turned out to be very prestigious
awards it's not a lot of money five
thousand dollars but professors now list
that as one of the top things that they
have one so it's gratifying that this
this relatively small award has turned
into such a prestigious thing I realized
when I started cybex that we were having
trouble recruiting people to Texas so I
also started the Texas nanotechnology
initiative to focus on bringing people
together to Texas that led to university
of texas at dallas starting up the
nanotech Institute and after ironed out
a bunch of money to start that they came
back and said we'd like to have a chair
and a chair for our first recipient of
that chair turned out to be the Nobel
Prize winner Alan McDermott who had
discovered conducting plastic and so
it's great to get to know him so anyway
I've been involved in nano for quite a
while so what do I mean by
nanotechnology well molecular
nanotechnology i defined is a precise
controlled rearrangement of atoms into a
higher value form so if we take the
carbon atoms in this lump of coal
they're not worth very much because
they're random and unstructured but if
we were to take those same atoms and
rearrange them into a crystal
they're dymond same carbon atoms just a
different structure suddenly what
they're worth a lot more money of course
if we were to take those and arrange
them into a different form leaving out
most of those atoms and putting them
just where we wanted we might have some
super strong materials we might have
some incredible computers and I think
the breakthrough that most people are
going to care about we could have some
amazing medical devices devices it
actually would go into your body tumble
around in your bloodstream get carried
to a spot where they might find the
right chemical environment start working
and cure cancer some people believe that
old age is a curable disease if it's
going to be cured it's going to be cured
by nano technology devices that can go
work at the scale of the molecules in
yourself nature is a nano technology
using endeavor and some of my favorite
examples are up here on the right we
have the abalone shell a micro picture
of that is a little nanostructured
plates of calcium carbonate which is
chalk layered together with a biopolymer
which i think of as snot so we are
structuring chalk and snot and by the
nano structuring in just the right
arrangement this material is 3,000 times
tougher than either material alone as an
engineer I think if I had today's strong
engineering materials which are better
that's not in chalk and I had the right
structuring what did we do with
materials to make some incredible things
that we can't make today because we
don't have control of the nano
structures and most of you are familiar
with the butterfly wings the iridescent
of those this morpho wing is interesting
they've just puzzled out the structure
actually probably in the last ten years
or so some of these nanostructures the
pictures the micro pictures from
electron microscope that you see here
you can't quite appreciate the detail
but they've analyzed how these interact
with the light that lands on this wing
to produce this very bright blue it's a
combination of the nano structures of
the wing some dyes
underneath these nanostructures that
absorb all the light that isn't blue but
it produces a very striking blue by
having structures smaller than way
length of light that play with the light
so I think if we can apply nano we're
going to see a lot of applications in
advanced materials clean cheap energy
maybe something a little bit more
efficient than today's solar cells
applied a little bit better plants are
great at hardening energy they're not
very efficient we could do better with
the right kind of nano structures and
computers we we calculated at one point
that if we built a computer the size of
a sugar cube with nanostructured
materials it would have more compute
power than all the computers ever built
in the world so how do we do this well
nature's been doing it since the first
life one of my favorite nanotech devices
that I sometimes bring along to a
conference with me is this acorn inside
this acorn there's an energy supply and
not the DNA the molecular material is a
computer program that says what to do
and this is full of little molecular
machines proteins and aggregations of
proteins that actually are molecular
motors that transport things around
inside this cell that rearranged the
molecules of dirt water and air which is
really all it has to work with it's a
solar-powered Factory and by rearranging
those atoms we're able to build an oak
tree which is really an acorn
manufacturing plant it's a pretty nice
Factory most of us would not mind having
this Factory in our backyard solar
powered produces excess energy it used
to be what what mankind built the world
out of is the wood and wood is a
fascinating material it's a
nanostructured composite similarly to
the abalone because of the the right
kinds of nanostructures apply it in the
right way it's strong light grows for
free we can cut it down turn it into
furniture it's it's a good start on
where we're going to go with nano in the
future
but we're an engineer we're an
engineering company i'm an engineer how
do we do this we're not going to work
with nature's efficiency we don't have
billions of years to evolve what we're
trying to do so i boiled this down when
i started i of x 22 really two things
positional chemistry how do we perform a
chemical reaction at a particular spot
so manipulate the environment so that
these molecules react the way we want
once we can do that then how do we do
the system design to build a factory to
let us do this in parallel because if we
have a machine that will do one chemical
reaction to this let's say we can do it
really fast a million a second it's
going to take billions of years for us
to build something big enough to see if
we're doing billions of reactions a
second so we need a huge parallel system
and in fact in our bodies in the tree
and every living thing we have millions
or billions or trillions of cells all of
which have a lot of molecular motors and
molecular machines inside doing the work
in parallel and that's really what's key
to making nanotech practical so we have
a couple of ways to look at it the wet
side which is the bio and the dry side
which is today's nano most people stop
it here at professors stop dividing it
in in these two columns I like to
separate into two rows also and say we
got passive things that just work
because of their shape or their charge
all of biotech is down and hear all of
drugs it's pretty lucrative endeavor
just with this one quadrant but nature
actually works up here that inside
ourselves inside living machines they're
active nano we have molecular motors
that are right now taking our lunch
disassembling it into the chemical
constituents reassembling it into things
like that and so I'm turning lunch into
me thanks to all these molecular
machines that are actively transporting
stuff around and ourselves are just
chock full of these molecular machines
so they manufacture by using machines at
a similar scale to the products that
they make which is what we do in a
machine shop
but most of nano today is down in this
area we're taking huge machines trying
to manipulate precise small things
doesn't work very well what we need is
to get a clue from nature and build
machines that are of a size similar to
the products they make build those
machines out of the products that they
make so we can bootstrap up and that's
what size x is trying to do so here's a
close-up view of the nano probing system
and what we have here is up to eight
probes that can land on an integrated
circuit these things are very sharply
etched tungsten wires we can actually
land one of them on a one micron square
and to give you a size of the nano scale
let me just go down the size scale we'll
start with a millimeter we go a tenth of
a millimeter 100 microns that's about
the diameter one of my course beard
hairs 100 microns hundred micrometers a
tenth of that 10 microns is about the
size of one of our cells a diameter of a
cell a tenth of that one micron is about
the size of bacteria a tenth of that 100
nanometers is about the size of a virus
a tenth of that 10 nanometers is about
the size of a large protein cluster
molecular machine a tenth of that one
nanometer is about the size of a large
molecule or the diameter of a nanotube
and a tenth of that one angstrom is
about the size of an atom so we go down
the Nano field that's interesting is in
the range of hundred nanometers size of
a virus down to about one nanometer size
of a large molecule so we're probing now
with this system semi conductor parts
that are down to about the 20 nanometer
size that's how about how big the
features of a transistor are these days
so this works in electron microscope
this is the high-end system cybex we buy
a commercial electron microscope rip off
the front door replace it with our own
nano probing stuff this whole rack has
developed by my company the software
that goes on it our first one was for
university work
sold for about a hundred thousand
dollars it sells for over two million
dollars in the high-end configuration
semiconductor industry can use this
probe one chip learn some design changes
to improve their yields and save tens of
millions of dollars a year per chip my
other company zywiec performance
materials had a breakthrough in
processing carbon nanotubes and we're
able to functionalize and solubilize and
process these things in a way no one
else has been able to do before or even
after which has allowed us to have a lot
of advanced materials we got interest
from some of our partner companies
Arkema French multinational chemical
company invested in here a few years ago
they make our nanotubes Lockheed Martin
made an investment both of those own
about ten percent of the company we have
our headquarters in Columbus Ohio but we
also have an office in richardson rapid
city south dakota and our newest ones
I've ex-marine up in Seattle so with
that we use carbon nanotubes about 15
years ago I guess they were discovered a
little rolled-up tubes of carbon they're
about a nanometer to a few nanometers in
diameter imagine chicken wire a
hexagonal chicken wire rolled up into a
tube if you take the chicken wire it's
kind of sloppy in the plane but if you
roll it up into a tube it becomes pretty
stiff and that's what makes nanotubes
great in the plane a nanotube is just
graphite which is carbon in a different
arrangement I talked about the diamond
which is carbon in a 3d arrangement
graphite is carbon in a 2d sheet it
turns out it's the strongest known
material it is the best known electrical
conductor and it is the best known heat
conductor it's a pretty amazing material
when you roll it up into a tube it also
becomes a very strong construction
material it's about a hundred times
stronger than conventional steel and
tensile strength now we're not getting
all of that property yet but we're able
to tap into a little of it so with that
we can make materials that are about
forty percent better than the industry's
best carbon fiber today and making this
advanced carbon fiber allows us to make
products like this bicycle we
are working on some aerospace
applications and where I'm really going
commercial here's in this boat there's a
picture of our boat up in Seattle the
guy that designed it president of the
company that makes it as I pecks
performance materials and I think I was
into chase boat here during our sea
trials our material is called arrow
pecks it's about as I said about a forty
percent improvement at mechanical
properties huge weight decrease in the
boat we're able to use less material
which makes the boat lighter which means
we can get smaller engines which means
we can go faster for a given amount of
fuel and the fuel usage in this bow this
is kind of a stripped-down model but the
fuel usage is pretty amazing so in
Singapore we're commercializing this new
boat called vigilant as an independent
unmanned surface vessel what that means
is that it's not a total robotic control
but we can send it out with human
monitoring in the loop over the
satellite we have two satellite domes on
here so we can run this boat from
anywhere in the world to anywhere in the
world as a range of almost 2,000 miles
so it could do what a human might not
want to do it would be very hard to go
out in this boat and be living in there
for a couple of weeks but the computer
doesn't matter the people on the shore
are happy being on the shore we had a
great epoxy a couple of years ago is
about also about forty percent better
than the best Deepak see we had a EPA
get involved in our business early last
year we had to sign a consent order that
basically banned us from selling it our
customers would have to get a permission
slip from the EPA they would have to
wear a full tie back bodysuit and a full
face respirator to handle this mix this
two-part epoxy apparently the EPA was
concerned that the nanotubes would
somehow escape from this viscous epoxy
and get into the air and be breathed
that is not possible in this
thermodynamic world but
but it was an interesting theory of
banning so we signed in the early part
of the last year we signed a consent
decree by the summer they were back to
us reneging on that degree and made a
sign another one so we basically don't
have that product for sale which is good
and bad it doesn't empower our
competitors we are willing to go through
the rigmarole of doing it so in our boat
yard we can have this epoxy that we use
to glue our boat together so we have a
competitive advantage over anyone else
we have a much better adhesive I just
heard earlier well I guess late last
year that bayer in germany it was one of
the world's largest manufacturers of
nanotubes they have shut down i heard
from a guy that was a senior manager
there who's looking for a job now in the
US the environmental has shut them down
even after they've demonstrated safety
they convince themselves that these
tubes are safe and the issue about the
new attitudes being unsafe is there they
have an aspect ratio like spaghetti so
there longer than their diameter well
asbestos has an aspect ratio like
spaghetti it's also longer than that's
diameter therefore attitudes must be
like asbestos because because they're
shaped like spaghetti so so that's the
argument for banning them in spite of
any real experimental labatts and
evidence to the contrary and there have
been some press release type studies
that indicate that we need to be careful
with this I am happy to say though that
we've had actually NIOSH is one of the
government agencies that seems to be a
little less wild about their accusations
they came in and looked at us and we
scored very very well better than any
other company in fact on handling of the
nanotubes and I figure as a deep pocket
rich guy I've got to have best practices
in my company I don't need the
government telling me to do stuff I'm
doing it because I fear lawyers on the
other side and I want to be sure that
our employees have a safe environment
export control I have some good news
here last year I was kind of grumpy
about that all because we had the sports
was the first market for our materials
they moved all the production of China
we could not follow because we were
export controlled our materials got
above a certain threshold the State
Department said we can't sell them
outside the US the State Department
didn't buy anything from us but they
also wouldn't let us sell just a couple
of months ago that real i was finally
relaxed we are now able to sell to just
about anybody that i want to sell to
with the exclusion of Iran and North
Korea which I don't really have any
commercial interest in so we are now
heading to Asia to look at some deals
and we may actually be able to have a
much more successful company getting
into many more products because of that
we had a cancer therapeutic that we were
working on a few years ago nanotubes if
they are put near a cancer turns out
they're very strong absorbers of radio
waves which was kind of unexpected we
had a professor at MD Anderson in
Houston who cured cancer in four out of
five rabbits using our nanotubes and
checked at nearby treating with radio
waves cooking the tumor cooks it in a
way that then the body suddenly turns on
recognizes that it's a cancer and goes
after it and cleans up any remaining
little little vestiges little cell
clusters that it finds but I got to
thinking about how long would it take to
actually get a real therapeutic to
market and I decided I can't afford to
go after 10 years and a billion dollars
I'm sorry to people with cancer that we
can't do anything about it but that's
just the case even our manufacturing of
boats in Seattle was an interesting
experience we had to build an oven our
whole boat a 54-foot boat is put in a
mold rolled in an oven cured overnight
at temperatures about 250 degrees
Fahrenheit we built this oven then the
inspectors came by and said well you
have to have a sprinkler system we said
it's an oven
and they said yes and it needs a
sprinkler system inside so we had to go
find high temperature sprinkler heads
and put a sprinkler system inside our
oven and then we also got into trouble
because the the gas lines inside it's a
gas fired oven code says 24 inches apart
for the supports my guys screwed up in a
major way we had our supports 18 inches
apart government said no no no 24 inches
so we had to move the supports from 18
inches to 24 inches apart so do you
think I'm going to be expanding my oven
in Seattle I give you one guess I'm now
applying the precautionary principle I
have taken that to heart here for my
business if I can't prove it's safe to
start a new company or invest in one in
the US it's better to do it elsewhere so
that's what is behind my move to
Singapore we are now in the spring we're
going to be launching an anti-piracy
joint venture with an anti pirate guy
based in Dubai and we're launching that
through our Singapore company with the
guy in Dubai actually taking the lead in
terms of the business development
because I don't want to contemplate the
legal aspects of having a company that
goes after pirates based in the US this
is a fanciful picture what we're trying
to do build 3d structures with atomic
precision if these blue atoms would be
silicon the green atoms would be
germanium we could preferentially we
build those as a 3d crystal but we could
preferentially etch away the germanium
freeing up a 3d object with atomic
precision so my goal here is to me lead
the commercialization of adaptable
affordable atomically precise
manufacturing throughout human history
we had what i call the blacksmith model
handcrafting the skilled artisan could
make almost anything out of the
materials they had at hand and we went
that way for millennia and we had a lot
of human progress thanks to that but
everything was a one-off you didn't get
any advantage of building one you might
know more the skills to build the next
one but you didn't really do it in a
good manufacturing way
ford had two great breakthroughs I think
Henry Ford realized if you had a machine
that would make a lot of identical parts
you could make the parts very cheaply
and if you had an assembly line that
could put them together with specialized
labor you could do assembly very cheaply
and the combination of cheap parts and
cheap assembly led to a revolution in
manufacturing the Intel Texas
Instruments breakthrough was the next
manufacturing breakthrough and realized
basically a photographic negative and
you shine light through it you can
expose on a substrate you can expose a
photographic pattern and you can then
etch and deposit on that and build up a
3d structure and if you're making
electronics you now have a flexible
manufacturing by just changing the mask
that you're shining the light through
changing the steps of doing the
manufacturing you have a factory called
a semiconductor wafer fab that can make
a huge variety of parts very cheaply and
because it's an area based thing the
area of the wafer is what's driving your
cost if you can make the parts on that
area smaller and smaller and smaller you
get more parts for the same area the
cost is kind of controlled by the area
not by how small the features are so the
smaller your features the more money you
can make the more functionality you can
put in it's kind of a software
manufacturing model in some ways where
we're going with atomically precise
manufacturing is to say how do we get
out of that two dimensional approach
into fully three-dimensional structures
we have to build the factory itself out
of the same technology that that its
manufacturing so the breakdown in the
semiconductor industry is happening
right now because the cost of the wafer
fab is becoming astronomical that's
three or four billion dollars to build a
new manufacturing facility now because
they're not profiting by making smaller
parts the technologies to make the chips
are not scaling it the same way that the
transistors are but if we had an
atomically precise manufacturing it's
making small precise parts those are
exactly what we need in the factory to
make cheaper factories so now we have a
double declining learning
as we get better at making the parts we
make more precise parts more cheaply we
put those together into the factory the
factory itself gets cheaper as the parts
get cheaper now we're on a double
declining learning curve the economics
of that are stunning you can just see
what has happened with with the the cost
of transistors the cost of electronic
functionality where only one dimension
is changing the partner you know the
cost per transistor is going down costs
of the factory is going up exponentially
imagine if both of those were going down
we now have manufacturing that is
basically making trending toward
infinitely complex objects at zero cost
sort of the economics of nature and how
much does it cost to make an acorn so
that's the exciting thing to me about
nanotechnology is what that does to the
cost of manufacturing I used to worry
about what does that mean for jobs what
does that mean for for human well-being
and then the more I studied free market
economics more I realized that's not a
question it really matters it's going to
make so much wealth in society we could
well see a world where only one percent
of the people actually do productive
creative things and the rest of them are
able to live off that one percent will
figure out a way to adapt I think those
of us who like to work will continue to
work those who don't hopefully will
allow us who do to continue to do our
thing and there will be enough wealth to
go around here's a cartoon of what we're
trying to do our current approach we
take a crystal of silicon which is these
blue atoms coat it with hydrogen with a
just white atoms so far that's
conventional semiconductor fabrication
the differences that we come down with
this scanning tunneling microscope a
very sharp probe similar to the one that
I showed you in the nano probing system
except even sharper sting ends in a
single atom if we do it right we can pop
off the individual hydrogen's where we
want we then shower down a molecule that
sticks where we popped off these
hydrogens and we grow up one layer that
would come back and repeat it we do that
over and over again we have built a 3d
struck
this is the system in our lab one of two
systems that we use to do that which an
ultra-high vacuum scanning tunneling
microscope this is the ultra-high vacuum
system it's about 110 trillionth of an
atmosphere of pressure inside here's a
not particularly sharp tip this is about
a one nanometer tip I wish it was pointy
her but there is about a 1 nanometer
radius and you can basically count the
atoms on that thing by putting this in a
transmission electron microscope you
can't really see it there but if you get
up close you can see a little structure
of lines in here those are the atomic
lattice planes of the tungsten atoms
that are in this tip then this is the
the platform where the scanning
tunneling microscope SAR to cylindrical
gold coated objects here the sample
rides on these rails the whole thing is
on a spring because it can't have
vibrations so some places have exotic
vibration damping ours is pretty
straightforward it's just in a little
industrial facility in Richardson Texas
we rely on these Springs to isolate this
from the surrounding vibration to allow
us to get atomic precision here's a
little structure we were doing our
sample preparation was not very good so
we have a lot of white dots on the
surface and this one we were showing the
repeatability of the lines we can make
here are some early structures that
we're starting to make atomically
precise patterns these rows by the way
our rows of silicon atoms each of these
rows represents two silicon atoms that
are paired together we popped the
hydrogen's off of these and you see
we're starting to build some atomically
precise structures it's a long way to go
to actually build this up into 3d but we
are making slow progress now the
long-term goal is to build a factory and
here's a fanciful picture from a movie
that was done a few years back on what a
factory might look like molecules come
in here through this sorting rotor and i
will say that these things mix atomic
precision and solid modeling in a way
that kind of it makes it easy to show a
video but it doesn't make it very clear
where all the atoms
are so don't look at this is as saying
matter is continuous here and discreet
here in reality the matter would be
discrete everywhere and this would all
be individual atoms but we have a rotor
that is big enough to take one of these
molecules in reject others that are not
the same molecule run them through this
little mill thing and over in this
compartment we have a concentration of
the particular molecule that is trying
to sort until we get a very pure version
of this molecule we then pick it up in
another binding pocket we deposited here
and have a building block that we can
then stack into another structure we
eventually build big factories that are
handling these little bricks carrying
around building useful stuff very
fanciful oh we're a long way from that
today but it's a great vision toward
which we're headed got one more effort
going on it's ibex labs a few years back
we ran into this Israeli company medical
device company we're now joint venturing
with them this is an outgrowth of some
of our silicon micromachining work that
we used to do building little 3d micro
machines we're actually partnering with
them to build this nano retina a bionic
eye if you will it's going to be a
little device about about that big it
will be implanted into your eye it's a
bed of nails electrodes chip and
basically a image sensor like a camera
would have powered by an infrared laser
in some glasses that the blind person
would wear the infrared laser shines
light which powers the device it uses
your own eyes lens to focus an image on
to the array the imaging array and then
it stimulates the nerves and we just
made our first package of that shipped
off the first five to our partners in
Israel last week so we're moving forward
with that pretty excited about the
potential there and I don't have to be
the guy getting through FDA approval we
have they tried and true medical Tropper
newer in Israel who's doing the work
of getting it approved and finding
partners so I'm happy to go work on
medical stuff if I have an expert who
really knows what they're doing you
might have heard about the National
nanotech initiative that was kicked off
in 99 Clinton signed a bill put about
400 million a year into it and suddenly
all the professors in the universities
that were dismissing nanotech as science
fiction overnight discovered that they
were doing nanotech and could they have
some of this money please and it became
a very popular thing oh world kicked off
nanotech initiatives we've ramped it up
to well over a billion a year in the
u.s. three billion a year in the rest of
the world even social studies
departments have found a way to play
talking about social responsibility and
you know are the right people being
brought in to nanotechnology we need
focus groups we need to ask humans the
populace what do they think of nano and
what should nano do for them it kind of
reminds me of hitchhikers guide to the
galaxy if you saw the final episode with
the marketing people are studying you
know fire and you know what do we want
out of fire are we really going to allow
fire to be used the private sector those
plowing forward within precise nano not
the atomic precision that I'm trying to
do but coatings sunscreen L'Oreal is one
of the biggest Pat enters in
nanotechnology they're doing huge amount
of work to make better cosmetics through
nanotech sunscreen is kind of
interesting because they take nano-sized
particles of various materials zinc
oxide is one of the favorites it's small
enough that it's smaller than the
wavelength of light visible light
doesn't see it it passes right over it
but it's bigger than the wavelengths of
ultraviolet light so it looks like a
block to ultraviolet so it mechanically
blocks the light from getting through so
instead of the white stuff that you
normally used to have in the early days
of sunscreen where it's kind of a
precise size with the Nano sunscreens
they're very carefully tuned to block
only the ultraviolet and allow visible
through so it
invisible at optical wavelengths we have
nano silver a number of companies
working on nano silver antibiotics turns
out that most bacteria can't deal with
silver ions so that's a very effective
antibiotic you might have heard of nano
pants a few years ago it was really big
nano clothes which you'd spill wine on
and it would just rinse off these
companies are making billions or maybe
even tens of billions in revenue today I
think they're all point solutions
they're not really leading to a nanotech
revolution but still it's a lucrative
business model I think the atomic
precision is key to really a
general-purpose manufacturing revolution
and as far as I know zybex is the only
company really working toward that end